oh you are looking great thank you so
are you I mean I feel like 30 is looking
really good on ya that's so nice of you
thank you so much it's it's you know
I've been in my 30s for like two days
it's been amazing
loving it honey you had a thought a
right yeah that's what I called it
yeah I'm really annoying with puns and
it's the worst with like the cats
premiere like everything is just like a
cat pun because it's an endless supply
of them so you'll have to slip some cat
puns into our interview naturally yeah a
lot of persuading to get you to you know
be included did it way did it take a lot
of persuading to have you appear in a
cat's movie no no no it was very easy
all they had to do was ask the cat of
yours did you look to for inspiration
maybe Olivia was it my cats were
actually no no help to me because
they're the cat that they're most like
in the movie is a cat called Jenny any
dots which rebel Wilson plays so when we
were in cat school I was just showing
pictures of my cats and videos and stuff
to the teacher of cat school named Sarah
who who was like can I send these to
rebel like this is perfect inspiration
for her cat so mike has didn't inspire
me but they I'd like to think that when
they were sent to rebel that they did
inspire her for her character
development she was you all were
incredible in this film what did you see
it yes I haven't seen it I had a special
screening last weekend one I was hoping
to catch up with you but I saw it and I
really enjoyed really I did no good it's
unique story so I think any time you
think of like humans becoming cast
really up okay yep it was really really
great
the song that you wrote for Frankie
thank you just nominating ya that's very
exciting and we're so honored by that
it's like so cool that the Hopa
decided to honor us in this way because
I wrote the song with Andrew Lloyd
Webber and it was like that alone was
just a life-changing dream come true
moment for me and it's one of those
songs that I feel like the movie doesn't
really make sense without that song
right it's not like it was just a song
that was stuck into the film this is a
character that's the lead character in
the film and in the original Broadway
production she doesn't have a song in
there in the production she's just a
ballerina
she just we don't ever hear from her so
I think it's amazing - it was amazing to
get to be the lyricist that actually
figured out what she was going to say
when she spoke what an epic position for
you to be in and lo congratulations the
Grammy thank you we're going to if you
got that Grammy forever yeah it would be
great yeah I'm not gonna not gonna seem
ambivalent about that at all that would
be amazing that song is one that I'm so
proud of I wrote it up on my own but at
the same time everyone in music this
year has just been killing it there's
been so much great stuff that's happened
and I'm so you know proud of the album
and proud of the song it's amazing to
have it nominated you never know what's
gonna happen at those things obviously
it would be like girl it's a great album
it's like you have a song for any kind
of like mood that you're in in life
thank you so much thank you you have fun
tonight okay
[Music]